There is something called
the CIE Lab space.
Sometime called Lab space but L a b
actually, where L is luminance, and
then, as you change the a and the b,
you end up with different colors.
I'm going to use the work color now,
instead of the more technical words
later which, which we'll use.
So here, you have a luminance of 25%,
so it's kind of darker.
And you see the greenish, reddish and
blueish things as you move around.
And then the middle is kind of gray,
right?
And as this, as luminance gets brighter,
the middle gets brighter, and
you get these lighter
variations in color.
And so
that's called the Lab color space.
And the idea is that
you've got luminance, and
you've got sort of how
saturated the color is.
And actually, what the,
what we call the color, but
what is ty,
typically referred to as the hue.
And that sometimes defined
you can think of the color
as a three-dimensional volume
of one sort or another, and
you'll see there's a whole bunch
of ways of representing it.
But the idea is that one way of thinking
about it is that down here is dark,
up at the top is brighter.
And as you move around this circle, so
it goes through 360 and around again,
is what's referred to as the hue, okay?
And as you move outside,
things become purer in color, all right?
So two systems that people use a lot
to talk about these things are called
sometimes hue saturation and lightness,
or sometimes hue saturation and value.
There are all different
kinds of color spaces.
These two can be drawn as sort
of these thick cylinders.
So down here again at the bottom,
things are dark.
Up at the top, things are light.
In hue saturation and lightness,
the whole top is white, which I think by
the way is an awful representation,
I'll tell you why in a second.
Down the whole thing in
the bottom is all black.
And as you go around,
you'd get different colors.
That's what you can see around here,
different hues.
And as you go from the middle to the
edge, you get more and more saturated.
So in the middle, everything is gray.
It goes from black to white through gray